[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend die
Recherchen der
korrektivreporter schlagen politisch
hohe Wellen auch der Bundeskanzler
äußert sich heute dazu we ja die
Erkenntnisse als solche nicht alle neu
sind die Zeiten in denen sich AFD
Politiker noch davor scheuten mit dem
österreichischen Extremisten selner
gemeinsam aufzutreten sind eh lang
vorbei und die laut korrektiven Potzdam
besprochenen umfänglichen
deportationspläne sind auch kein neues
Gedankengut unter hochrangigen AFD
Leuten das kann man schon lange bei
Björn höcke etwa nachlesen der mit Zitat
wohltpratierter Grausamkeit volksteil
entfernen will die nicht über die rechte
Gesinnung verfügen allerdings befeuert
das potzdammer Treffen die Debatte über
ein mögliches Verbotsverfahren gegen die
AFD dazu gleich noch ein Gespräch
zunächst berichtet Karl
Hinterleitner die Empörung geht quer
durchs politische Berlin anlass ist das
Treffen zwischen hochrangigen afdlon und
rechtsradikalen Netzwerkern in diesem
Hotel in Potzdam im November mit Plänen
Millionen Menschen aus Land zu
vertreiben das sei illegal und klar
verfassungswidrig so die
bundesinnenministerin ich kann ihn noch
nicht im Detail sagen wie wir das
bewerten aber das was wir gesehen haben
was der Verfassungsschutz schon
ausgewertet hat ist völkisches
Gedankengut was dort bei diesem Treffen
vereinbart wurde und deswegen erwarte
ich auch dass alle die da in der Nähe
sich befinden oder das auch nur
annährend irgendwie gut finden sich
davon distanzieren weil das verstößt
klar gegen unsere Regeln des
Grundgesetzes von Distanzierung bei der
AFD wenig zu spüren im Gegenteil auf X
vormals Twitter bekräftigt ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter der AFD seine
Partei sei für massenhafte
Vertreibungen wir werden Ausländer in
ihre Heimat zurückführen millionenfach
das ist kein Geheimplan das ist ein
Versprechen politische Beobachter sind
alarmiert aber nicht wirklich überrascht
was sie hier erlebt haben ist eine
Enthüllung von der man eigentlich hätte
wissen müssen und können denn die AFD
ist auch wenn sie sich jetzt moderater
gibt in weiten Teilen genauso
rechtsextrem wie der Kontakt im Hotel
ist gezeigt hat sie kooperiert mit
rechtsradikalen die eines im Schilde
führen eine echte Abschaffung der
Demokratie ein Verbot der AFD sieht der
Justizminister dennoch skeptisch denn
sollte es vor Gericht scheitern dann
droht hier natürlich ein prsieg für die
AFD und dann hätte man am Ende
rechtsradikales rechtsextremes
rechtsextremistisches zumindest
rechtspopulistisches Gedanken nicht
bekämpft sondern möglicherweise gestärkt
ein Verbotsverfahren also riskant
letztlich helfe gegen Extremismus nur
die politische
Auseinandersetzung darüber wollen wir
mit einem Staatsrechtler sprechen mit
Christian waltorf er ist Professor an
der Humbold Universität in Berlin und
war
Prozessbevollmächtigter des Bundesrats
beim NPD Verbotsverfahren das 2017
eingestellt wurde guten Abend Herr
Professor walthoff guten Abend was ein
Prozess bevollmächtig da ist also wenn
ich das so leinenhaft sage dann haben
sie waren sie quasi der Rechtsvertreter
der Bundesländer bei diesem
Verbotsantrag genau mit einem Kollegen
zusammen ja mit Christoph Möllers aus
dieser Erfahrung heraus und sie haben
sich da ja intensiv mit der Frage
beschäftigt in wie fern man Parteien
verbieten lassen kann gehören sie jetzt
in der aktuellen Debatte eher zu den
Skeptikern oder eher zu den Befürwortern
eines
Verbotsverfahrens also zur Zeit gehöre
ich noch eher zu den Skeptikern eines
Verbotsverfahrens wir haben damals
gesehen wie komplex das ist wie hoch die
Hürden sind das ist auch richtig dass
die Hürden hoch sind weil man natürlich
nicht einfach unliebsame Parteien in
einer Demokratie verbieten kann und
besonders komplex sind etwa auch die
rechtsstaatlichen Anforderungen an ein
solches Verfahren also ein ein faires
Verfahren was da ein bisschen komisch
ist und was man jetzt auch als lei
schwer versteht damals ist dieses NPD
Verfahren nicht eingestellt worden weil
die NPD nicht verfassungswidrig gewesen
wäre das haben auch die karlsoher
richichte so gesehen sondern man sagte
die ist nicht bedeutend
und jetzt ist ein Argument zu sagen man
sollte das besser gar nicht erst
versuchen mit einem Verbotsverfahren
gegen die aft weil sie bereits zu groß
und zu bedeutend ist und zu viele Wähler
hat also entweder zu klein oder zu groß
also dieses Kriterium dass die NPD zu
bedeutungslos ist und deshalb obwohl sie
eine Nazipartei letztlich im Kern ist
nicht verboten wurde hat das Gericht in
dem Urteil von 2017 frei erfunden das
steht so im Grundgesetz gar nicht drin
sondern war sozusagen richterische
rechtsschöpfung des Bundes des
Verfassungsgerichts
ähm das ist ja der einzige Punkt der bei
der AFD überhaupt nicht strittig sein
kann dass sie nicht zu klein ist oder
nicht zu bedeutungslos um verboten zu
werden das heißt bei einem möglichen AFD
Verbotsverfahren liegen die Probleme
nicht bei der Bedeutung der Partei
sondern bei der Frage ob die
Voraussetzungen für ein äh Verbot sonst
erfüllt sind ob das eine
verfassungsfeindliche Partei im Sinne
des parteienverbotsartikels ist da
gibt's jetzt auch die Diskussion ob
dieses Pots dam mal treffen das nun
gerade furoro gemacht hatte mit diesem
ja Vertreibung von Millionen Menschen
auch nach ethnischen Kriterien nicht nur
nach juristischen und so weiter und der
Teilnahme von doch recht einflussreichen
AFD Leuten die dabei waren unter anderem
der persönliche Referent der
Parteichefin ob das irgendwie juristisch
eine Rolle spielen könnte wie ist da
ihre Einschätzung das könnte natürlich
irgendwie eine Rolle spielen aber allein
das reicht nicht aus das war ja keine
Veranstaltung der
AFD sondern man müsste solch
Vorkommnisse der Partei zurechnen können
und das ist nicht trivial ich meine wenn
hochrangige Politiker hochrangige
funktioniere wie der
Fraktionsvorsitzende aus SachsenAnhalt
oder der persönliche Referent der
parteichfin teilnehmen geht das schon in
die Richtung dass es vielleicht doch
zugerechnet werden kann aber so etwas
müsste es natürlich flächendeckend geben
das dürfen keine punktuellen Ereignisse
sein sondern im Grunde müssten die
Sicherheitsbehörden Material sammeln
dass das charakteristisch für die
Gesamtpartei ist sie sagen gesamt Partei
es gibt ja in auch von
Verfassungsjuristen die Überlegung oder
den Hinweis dass man gar nicht unbedingt
versuchen muss die gesamte Partei zu
verbieten sondern dass man es sozusagen
kleiner anfangen könnte also ein
einzelneen Landesverband oder auch
einzelne Personen wenn man jetzt z.B an
an börn höcke denkt also ob man einen
einzelnen also das
Bundesverfassungsgericht könnte auf
einen Verbotsantrag hin auch einzelne
nur einzelne Landesverbände verbieten
das sieht das Gesetz vor äh die
herrschende Meinung zu drück dass die
Juristen ja immer auss sagt aber man
müsste trotzdem ein Verbotsantrag gegen
die Gesamtpartei erstmal stellen dann
geh wir sozusagen ein kleineres Stück
heraus nicht die Gesamtpartei wäre dann
vielleicht verboten sondern vielleicht
ein besonders extremistischer
Landesverband das Grundgesetz sieht auch
vor dass
Einzelpersonen ihre Grundrechte im
politischen Meinungskampf verwirken
können wenn sie diese Grundrechte z.B
die Meinungsfreiheit oder die
Versammlungsfreiheit im Kampf gegen das
Grundgesetz gegen die Verfassung
einsetzen das ist eine sogenannte
grundrechtsverwirkung Artikel 18 des
Grundgesetzes davon wurde freilich in
der Geschichte des Grundgesetzes oder
der Bundesrepublik noch nie Gebrauch
gemacht die Hörden liegen vermutlich
auch dort hoch ja und das würde ja
einzelne Personen da sozusagen jetzt in
Anführungszeichen herauszuschießen würde
ja auch gar nicht den Effekt bringen
vielleicht sogar gegenteilige Effekte
müsste man befürchten die man mit einem
Parteiverbot vielleicht erreichen wollte
sagt der Staatsrechtler Herr Professor
waltoff danke ih für das Gespräch und
die Expertise
gerne extremismusforscher gehen davon
aus dass man Menschen mit einem
geschlossenen völkisch nationalistischen
Weltbild kaum noch erreichen kann
wichtiger sei es sich auf jene zu
konzentrieren die zwar unzufrieden und
wütend sind sich aber noch nicht
grundsätzlich vom demokratischen System
verabschiedet haben das Wählerpotenzial
für radikale Parteien sei unter anderem
dort groß wo es starke Veränderungen und
damit ein gehende Verlustängste gibt
wenn die Analyse zutrifft auch wenn Sie
sicher keine alleinige Erklärung sein
kann dann können Regierungen etwa mit
Strukturpolitik zumindest versuchen
gegenzusteuern Katin Lindner mit einem
Beispiel dafür aus der
Lausitz Luzi bobusch darf heute neben
dem Kanzler stehen für die 21-Jährige
gibt es wieder Perspektiven sie hat im
Tagebau der leer gelernt doch nach der
Lehre ging die tagebaauoß
geräteschlosserin zur Bahn in der Kohle
ist mein Opa mein Onkel viele Freunde
Bekannte weshalb ich auch zu leer
gegangen bin ist einfach so ein Stück
Familie und gegangen bin ich eigentlich
nur weil es ja hieß dass es beendet
werden beendet wird dass die Kohle nicht
mehr lange geht und da wurden wir auch
alle nicht übernommen Olaf Scholz will
einen Erfolg in cotbus feiern das
modernste Werk der Bahn ist entstanden
und bringt gut bezahlte
Industriearbeitsplätze in die Region die
den kohaausstieg schaffen muss 1200
Arbeitsplätze sollen hier
entstehen das zeigt der Trend dreht sich
oder hat sich schon gedreht hier in
cotbus und an vielen ganz anderen vielen
anderen Orten in
Ostdeutschland es sind ja nicht nur
diese riesigen Hallen der Bahn die schon
entstanden sind und noch gebaut werden
das bahnwerk setzt Impulse für das ganze
Umfeld
Ende Dezember hat er nicht weit von
kottbus entfernte Tagebau jinchwalde den
Betrieb eingestellt weitere werden
folgen bis 2 38 soll das letzte
Kohlekraftwerk stillgelegt werden Mittel
für den strukturumbau vom Bund flossen
in das neue Werk der Bahn es wird sehr
dringend deutschlandweit benötigt
nachdem in Nürnberg kein ICE Werk
gewollt
war ist es ein Segen dass es in Cottbus
terminingerechtfertigt wird jetzt steht
eine moderne Halle noch eine zweite soll
folgen Instandhaltung in Cottbus hat
eine lange Tradition 150 Jahre doch das
alte W stand lange auf der Kippe weil
wenige diesellocks gewartet werden
mussten über Jahre auf kommunaler auf
Landesebene auf Bundesebene muss man
wirklich kämpfen dass das überhaupt
erhalten bleibt und jetzt entsteht hier
das modernste ICE Werk Europas kämpfen
sind sie hier also gewohnt und während
im Werk die Eröffnung läuft machen
draußen die Bauern ihrem Unmut Luft ich
habe halt einen Vorgesetzten Milchpreis
bei mir im Stall ich kriege den Preis
von der Molkerei vorgegeben und kann
nicht anders handeln und wir können
einfach nicht mehr zu den Landwirten die
um ihre Perspektive Ringen ist der
Kanzler nicht gekommen er sprach mit
ihrem Landespräsidenten auch in der
Agrarwirtschaft da verlieren wir derzeit
Produktionsstandorte da sind wir derzeit
im Strukturwandel und ich glaube das war
auch die Botschaft des Gespräches dass
man hier nach nach Lösung suchen sollte
gemeinsam um auch die Landwirtschaft
nicht nur fürs nächste Jahr festzumachen
sondern auch fürs übernächste Jahr oder
am besten noch für die nächsten 10 Jahre
und so kann man in cotbus heute doppelt
spüren Strukturwandel kostet viel Kraft
und auch
Geld schön wäre natürlich wenn man in
cotbus nicht nur ICE Züge instand setzen
würde sondern auch einen IC anchluss
hätte den gibt's biser nicht und dann
schauen wir jetzt auf die internationale
Politik das Denner ostkonflikt im
Allgemeinen und der aktuelle Krieg
zwischen Israel und der Hamas im
Besonderen polarisiert das ist ja nicht
neu zum Teil hat das auch historische
Wurzeln auch der nostkonflikt war
jahrzehntelang vom Kalten Krieg
überwölbt mit den USA auf der einen und
der Sowjetunion auf der anderen Seite
das spielt zum Teil bis heute eine Rolle
etwa wenn jetzt Südafrika Israel wegen
seines Vorgehens in Gaza vor dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof in Den hach
anklagt der südafrikanische ANC wurde
während der apartheitszeit von der
sowjetun unterstützt die USA und Israel
wurden hingegen als Förderer des weißen
apartheitsregimes
gesehen be der deutschen Bundesregierung
stößt die Klage auf Unverständnis Israel
empfindet sie als verleäumdung vom
Auftakt vor Gericht berichtet Florian
Neuhann es ist Tag 96 nach dem Angriff
der hammas auf Israel Tag 75 nach Beginn
der israelischen Bodenoffensive da
kommen in der den Hag sehr gemessenen
Schrittes 17 Richterinnen und Richter
auf die Bühne und dieser Nahostkrieg
erstmals vor ein
Weltgericht den Hag der Internationale
Gerichtshof auf der Anklagebank heute
der Staat Israel es geht um den wohl
härtesten Vorwurf überhaupt Völkermord
definiert als Handlungen in der Absicht
eine nationale ethnische rassische oder
religiöse Gruppe als solche ganz oder
teilweise zu
die Anklage ist sich
sicher israel hat eine unvergleichliche
beispiellose Zahl von Zivilisten getötet
im vollen wissen wie viele Leben jede
einzelne Bombe
beendet niemand in Gaza wird verschont
nicht einmal neugeborene Babys
über dre Stunden präsentiert Südafrika
sorgfältig vorbereitet seinen Fall ob
mit Soldaten die nach erfolgreichen
Angriffen
jubilieren oder mit Zitaten handelnder
Politiker die zur Zerstörung von Gaza
aufgerufen haben man will Absicht
belegen und sich ganz nebenbei zum
Wortführer aufschwingen des wachsenden
ch der Israelkritiker weltweit
Unterstützung für das palästinensische
Volk darauf können sich in Südafrika
nämlich fast alle einigen man setzt den
Kampf der Palästinenser gleich mit der
eigenen Geschichte dem Kampf gegen die
apaththeit schon zu Zeiten von Nelson
Mandela und
ex-palästinenserpräsident Yasir
Arafat die regierende Partei in
Südafrika der ANC war eine
Befreiungsbewegung und Teil einer
weltweiten Bewegung die gegen
Kolonialismus Imperialismus und für die
Freiheit kämpfte wie Nelson Mandela
einmal gesagt hat unsere Freiheit ist
nicht vollständig solange es andere gibt
die ihre noch nicht erreicht
haben Taten der Hamas kommen in der
Anklage heute nur als Anlass vor Israel
das vor Gericht ersten Morgen zu Wort
kommt ist heute schon empört das Land
fürchtet um seinen Ruf am Abend meldet
sich der
Premier wir kämpfen gegen Terroristen
und wir kämpfen gegen Lügen heute haben
wir eine verkehrte Welt erlebt dem
israelischen Staat wird Völkermord
vorgeworfen während er selbst gegen
Völkermord
kämpft ob es ein Ende der militärischen
Handlungen verlangt das könnte das
Gericht schon bald entscheiden
durchsetzen kann es seine Urteile zwar
nicht doch verhandelt wird in den Hag
auch über die Meinungshoheit
weltweit und jetzt macht erstmal Heinz
Wolf weiter mit anderen Nachrichten des
Tages der britische Premierminister
sunak hat Medienberichten zufolge am
Abend sein Kabinett zu telefonischen
Beratungen einberufen es geht dai wohl
um möglicherweise bevorstehende
gemeinsame Militärschläge mit den USA
gegen die Husi Rebellen im Jemen seid
Ausbruch des Gazakrieges zwischen Israel
und der islamistischen Hamas greifen die
Husi immer wieder Schiffe mit angeblich
israelischer Verbindung im Roten Meer an
große Redereien meiden die wichtige
handelsrutee
zunehmend die SPD Bundestagsfraktion ist
in Berlin zu einer
jahresauftagtklausur zusammengekommen
und beschloss die Forderung nach einer
Reform der Schuldenbremse Fraktionschef
Mützenich sagte Schulden sein für
Deutschland nicht nur tragbar sie sein
notwendig um invtien zu tätigen damit
Deutschland seine spitzenstellungen der
Welt auch
behaupte innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
stellt sich vor allem die FDP von
Finanzminister Lindner gegen eine
Lockerung der Schuldenbremse und eine
erneute Aussetzung in diesem
Jahr cduchef März hat angesichts des
laufenden Streiks der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL im
Tarifkonflikt mit der Deutschen Bahn ein
Eingreifen der Bundesregierung gefordert
der Bund als bahneigentümer habe jetzt
eine Verantwortung sagt im März der
Rheinischen Post Verkehrsminister
Wissing müsse alle Beteiligten an einen
Tisch holen wie schon gestern sind im
Fernverkehr etwa 80% der Züge
ausgefallen auch im Regionalverkehr kam
es zu erheblichen Beeinträchtigungen der
Streik soll noch bis morgen Abend
andauern Außenministerin bbock hat auf
ihrer Asienreise China angesichts dessen
aggressiven Vorgehens im südchinesischen
kritisiert bei ihren Gesprächen in der
philippinischen Hauptstadt Manila sagte
berbock riskante Manöver der
chinesischen Küstenwache stellten für
Länder weltweit die völkerrechtlich
verbriefte Freiheit der Seewege in Frage
das Außenministerium in Peking reagierte
umgehend und betonte kein Land das nicht
zur Region gehöre habe das Recht in
Konflikte um das südchinesische mehr
einzugreifen in Polen haben Anhänger der
nationalk
Oppositionspartei peace gegen die Mitte
Linksregierung von Ministerpräsident
Tusk demonstriert mehrere tausend
Menschen versammelten sich vor dem
Parlament in Warschau ihr Protest
richtete sich gegen die jüngsten
Reformen der öffentlichrechtlichen
Medien und gegen die Verhaftung zweier
verurteilter Politiker der peace
vorgestern Polens Staatsoberhaupt duda
der der peace Partei nahe steht kündigte
an die beiden erneut zu
begnadigen
bundesgesundheitsministerl hat heute
eine Ankündigung gemacht von der selbst
wohlmeinende befürchten dass er damit in
ein westennest sticht in eh schon
erregten Zeiten denn der Glaube an die
Segnungen der Homöopathie ist weit
verbreitet künftig soll sie aber keine
von der Allgemeinheit finanzierte
Kassenleistung mehr sein die finanzielle
Entlastung die dadurch entsteht hält
sich in Grenzen aber das dürfte auch
nicht Lauterbachs Hauptmotivation sein
in erster L
geht es wohl darum im Abrechnungssystem
der Kassen das Prinzip der
wissenschaftlichen Evidenz durchzusetzen
gefordert wird das mit Blick auf die
homöopathiebranche schon lange Christina
Kerz und Dorte Ferber
berichten dass diese Kügelchen wirksam
sein könnten daran gibt es von jeher
Zweifel dennoch setzen auch
schulmedizinisch ausgebildete Ärzte auf
homöopathische Behandlungen einer von
ihnen ist Jürgen de laaport
niedergelassener Facharzt für Innere
Medizin gerade in der Allgemeinmedizin
in diesem breit ausgesuchten
Patientengut ist es so dass der Bereich
dazwischen nämlich dieser Bereich wo es
nicht ganz gesund und nicht ganz krank
ist der größte ist und da geht es drum
der Allgemeinmedizin nennt das das
abwartende offen lassen wenn man dann
die Chance hat dort dem Patienten etwas
mitzugeben und er merkt dass man sich
wirklich für ihn interessiert und genau
reinfragt was ist denn sonst noch alles
um die Beschwerde dann kann man mit
einem Medikament begleiten und hat damit
oft sehr gute Erfolge Karl Lauterbach
will das nicht gelten lassen ihm geht es
ums Prinzip keine nachgewiesene
Wirksamkeit kein Geld von den
gesetzlichen Kassen erklärt der
Gesundheitsminister heute in Berlin die
höopathie ist eine Leistung die keinen
medizinischen Nutzen auf der Grundlage
des wissenschaftlichen Sachstandes
erbringt dann sollte eine solche
Leistung auch nicht bezahlt werden die
Krankenkassen sollten nicht
Krankenkassenleistungen bezahlen die
medizinis nichts bringen das können wir
uns nicht lassen auch gut 200 Jahre
nachdem Samuel Hanemann die Grundsätze
der Homöopathie formuliert hat gelten
Studien die den Zusammenhang von
Behandlung und Heilung nachweisen sollen
als unzureichend generell kann ich kann
ich sagen dass wir für die
evidenzbasierte Medizin stehen und dass
damit auch gilt dass natürlich
Behandlung die dann auch von der
Gemeinschaft übernommen werden schon
möglichst gut evidenzbasiert sein soll
und man kann glaub ich auch festhalten
dass das bei der hopathie eher fraglich
ist längst nicht alle gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen haben die homöopathische
Behandlung als freiwillige Leistung in
ihrem Angebot und die Preise für Globoli
sind gering das Einsparpotenzial ist
deshalb überschaubar von rund 290
Milliarden Gesamtkosten könnten es nach
Angaben des Ministeriums 20 bis 50
Millionen sein die Opposition spricht
von einer Nebel Herze und der Arzt de
laport sieht mehr Schaden als Nutzen für
die Patienten würde es bedeuten dass
dann die besser verdienenden das
weiterhin bezahlt bekommen würden die
privat verersichert sind aber diejenigen
die es jetzt von den Kassen erstattet
bekommen nicht mehr und das würde ich
ungerecht finden
überzeugte Anhänger der Homöopathie wird
ein Verbot wohl nicht abschrecken für
einige Unruhe in Arztpraxen könnte der
Vorstoß des Ministers allerdings
Sorgen und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal
weiter mit dem Blick auf die Finanz
Märkte die US wertpapieraufsicht sec hat
eine lange erwartete Entscheidung
bekannt gegeben sie hat den Weg für
börsenehandelte Bitcoin Fonds
freigemacht klingt kompliziert Valerie
Haller was ist das für eine
Anlageform damit können Bitcoins zum
ersten Mal an der Börse gehandelt werden
in Form von Fonds die von
Vermögensverwaltern aufgelegt werden man
muss nun also nicht mehr über den Umweg
über eine kryptobörse mit potenziell
windigen Plattform gehen stattdessen
erwirbt man über regulierte Anbieter
einen fondanteil mit dem man jederzeit
ein oder aussteigen kann für die
kryptoindustrie gilt das als Wendepunkt
der Handel mit Bitcoins wird dadurch
einfacher und professioneller was ihn
für Menschen nun interessanter machen
dürfte analysten erwarten Zuflüsse in
Milliardenhöhe zunächst stieg der Kurs
von Bitcoins stark an jetzt bröckelt er
aber wieder das zeigt der Handel mit
Bitcoins mag nun sicherer sein doch
wirklich sicher ist die Anlage damit
noch lange nicht fällt der Bitcoin
kururs verliert auch der Fond an Wert
und die Kursschwankungen können riesig
sein Anleger haben schon viel Geld
verloren mit Bitcoins auch Totalverlust
ist nicht ausgeschlossen daran ändert
auch die neue fondregelung nichts selbst
die amerikanische Börsenaufsicht die
gerade grünes Licht gegeben hat warnt
Bitcoins sei eine spekulative Anlageform
die auch für Geldwäsche und
Terrorismusfinanzierung verwendet werde
an leger sollten vorsichtig sein
hinsichtlich der zahlreichen Risiken wer
her vielen
Dank bei der Bahnrad EM in den
Niederlanden gab es heute eine weitere
zwei weitere Medaillen für das deutsche
Team Gold holten im Zweier
Mannschaftsfahren Roger Kluge und sein
Partner Theo Reinhard der Frauen Vierer
gewann Bronze hinter Italien und
Großbritannien beim Heimweltcup in
rupolding hat die deutsche
biathlonstaffel der Männer den zweiten
Platz belegt in einem spannenden Rennen
schien der erste Staffelsieg eines DSV
Quartetts seit knapp 3 Jahren lange
möglich zwei Strafrunden im Stehen
schießen warfen die deutschen dann
zunächst wieder weit zurück doch
Schlussläufer Philip nawrad rettete den
protestplatz hinter den siegreichen
Norwegern Italien kam auf Rang
3 was ein russisches Gefängnis aus einem
machen kann ahnt man wenn man sich Putin
Kritiker Alexi navalni ansieht vor und
nach seiner Inhaftierung derzeit soll er
wieder in einer Isolationszelle sitzen
in einer Strafkolonie am Ende der Welt
in der russischen Polarregion das Lager
ist eine Nachfolgeeinrichtung des
sowjetischen gulaks jene straf und
Arbeitslager in denen Stalin im Laufe
der Zeit Millionen Sowjetbürger
einweisen ließ über diese Orte der
Verdammnis berichteten inhaftierte
Schriftsteller wie solchenizin oder der
im Westen bislang eher unbekannte Georgi
demidorf von ihm ist nun erstmals ein
Kurzroman ins Deutsche übersetzt worden
Christ hat lepple stellt ihn vor
Endstation kollimar das Ausschwitz ohne
Öfen die Straße zum gulak wurde auf den
Knochen der Gefangenen erbaut diese
holten bei Eiseskälte Kohle Uran oder
Gold aus der sibirischen Erde einer von
vielen geori
Physiker zehn Mal war ich halbtot
zweimal lag ich wegen Unterkühlung im
Sterben das schwor ich mir dass ich
überleben werde nur um diese Hölle zu
beschreiben erst jetzt ein halbes
Jahrhundert später erscheint in
Deutschland seine unglaubliche
Geschichte sie heißt fquas oder der
Idiot fquas ist Hebräisch und bedeutet
Narr oder Idiot der Plot der unschuldige
Romanheld erfindet im Verhör absurde
Sabotage Akte die unmöglich sind in der
Hoffnung freigesprochen zu werden dieser
beliebte Vergleich mit Kafka jemand
musste verhaftet sein und wusste nicht
warum und seine Aufgabe besteht in den
folgenden Wochen darin herauszukriegen
warum bin ich eigentlich verhaftet
worden der Plan scheitert Stalin System
aus Absurdität und Brutalität kennt kein
Erbarmen jeder ist verdächtig die
Paranoia des Großen Terrors demidorf
beschreibt Hunger Schlafmangel Folter
nächtliche Verhöre in den Zellen stinkt
es erbärmlich aus dem einzigen Kübel nur
morgens frisches Wasser abends nicht
Menschen sterben wie fliegen demidorfs
gulakdkument geht unter die Haut das ist
leider sehr aktuell und ich kann sagen
dass ich habe mit dem Buch gearbeitet
und parallel russische Nachrichten
gelesen und das ist schrecklich dass
diese Geschichte sich wiederholt
Physiker demidorf überlebt 14 Jahre in
Stalin Lagern 1964 wird sein Roman
fertig das Manuskript bleibt in der
Schublade 1980 werden alle Texte
beschlagnamt auch seine drei
Schreibmaschinen hier das Protokoll der
Mann ist
verzweifelt es fällt mir schwer zu
beurteilen welchen Sinn mein Schreiben
hat wahrscheinlich nur denselben den das
zwangsläufige knan einer Maus hat um
Ihre Zähne abzuwetzen ich habe
jedenfalls keine Hoffnung veröffentlicht
zu werden 1987 stirbt der mit zwei Jahre
später unter gorbschow erhält die
Tochter seine Texte zurück zu spät es
dat weitere 30 Jahre bis dieses
aufrüttelnde Buch erscheint deshalb ist
es sehr aktuell ich glaube das ist
könnte man auf das Verfahren gegen
navalni z.B anwenden dem geht's gerade
genauso von den Haftbedingungen bis zu
den
bizarren Beschuldigungen unter denen er
da steht eine echte Entdeckung dieser
gulakroman beklemmt brisant und sehr
empfehlenswert das war's im heutejournal
gleich geht's bei Maybritt ilner weiter
in ihrer Runde sitzen heute unter
anderem Jim ösimir Henrik wüst und die
Schriftstellerin und Juristin juli C und
um 030 Uhr meldet sich der NAS g mir mit
unserem he Schal Update bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
wiersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend wie eine Spinne in ihrem
wetternetz hockt das hochannelore über
Großbritannien jetzt kommt ein bisschen
Bewegung ins Wetter da kommen Tiefs
heran und die bringen nicht nur Wolken
mit sondern auch ein bisschen Regen oder
Schnee das merken wir schon in dieser
Nacht da kann es nämlich auch mal
gefährlich glatt sein auf Straßen und
Gehwegen wenn da so ein bisschen
Schneegriesel oder Nieselregen fällt im
Süden ist es zum Teil klar die
Temperaturen sinken meist auf -1 bis
-12° milder bleibt die Nacht im
Nordwesten mit 3° dort erwarten uns
morgen Höchsttemperaturen von 3 bis 6°
sonst liegen die Höchstwerte um den
Gefrierpunkt in Norddeutschland ist es
morgen meist trüb und bedeckt die Sonne
sehen sie allenfalls mal hier Richtung
ostseküste oder nördliches
Schleswig-Holstein es fällt ein bisschen
Regen und in der Mitte ist nach wie vor
noch so ein bisschen Schneegriesel ni
Regen und Schnee zu erwarten da bleibt's
also glatt anders sieht's in
Süddeutschland aus besonders zwischen
dem Breigau und dem Alpenvorland scheint
die Sonne zum Teil strahlend am
Wochenende ziehen erst über den Norden
dann auch über den Nordosten und am
Montag auch über den Südosten dichtere
Wolken mit Schnee Schneeregen und
Nieselregen hinweg und dann wird es auch
ein bisschen milder anders sieht's im
Südwesten aus da bleibt es die ganze
Zeit überfreundlich und wie sie hier am
Trend für Stuttgart sehen können bleibt
es vor allen Dingen nachts auch noch
länger Frost bis Mitte nächster Woche
ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend